let's talk about John Bolton briefly
there are multiple new reports out that
Donald Trump is keeping a list of people
who crossed him during his presidency
who he would like to get locked up
eventually and his own former national
security adviser John Bolton is
reportedly on that list we heard this
from Rick Wilson we've had Rick on the
show longtime Republican strategist he's
an anti-trump Republican he says that
Donald Trump is likely to start putting
pressure on the Justice Department to
try to get revenge on people like Bolton
Bolton of course recently saying that in
his upcoming book in the manuscript
portion that was released says that
Donald Trump personally told him
withhold the Ukraine aid until Ukraine
smears Joe Biden publicly of course the
Senate is expected to vote to acquit
Donald Trump tomorrow Wednesday in the
Senate Rick Wilson says that John Bolton
has one choice right now and that John
Bolton must leak the full manuscript of
the book today
the reason Wilson says this is that if
Bolton doesn't leak the full transcript
with additional context and assertions
related to what Trump told him about
Ukraine Trump gets acquitted tomorrow
and then ruins Bolton's life Wilson says
Bolton's only shot is to try to get the
full story out today of what he saw
Trump do get it into the public before
the Senate votes to make the vote look
like a sham kangaroo court vote which of
course is exactly what that vote will be
investigative reporter Gabriel Sherman
says it's not just Bolton on Trump's
enemies list it's Republicans and
Democrats Adam Schiff is on Trump's list
Jerry Nadler is on Trump's list even
Republican senator Mitt Romney from Utah
is reportedly on that list I can imagine
this list of enemies written in crayon
on a napkin from Kentucky Fried Chicken
that Trump was eating on Air Force One
but it doesn't matter because this is a
dystopian reality
Sherman reports that he was told Trump
wants John Bolton criminally
investigated one possibility would be
for the mishandling of classified
information that Trump seems to think
John Bolton was engaged in which is
truly even a true call the pot
pot calling the kettle black when he
were Donald Trump talking about miss
handling sensitive information there's
another report that Trump wants to leak
emails showing that bolton was doing
pay-to-play
while on the national security council
that's been denied by people close to
bolton if this happens the transition to
full-blown authoritarian dictatorship
will be complete
the attempted jailing of former elected
officials and of administration
officials on trumped-up charges as
directed by the president now this is a
good opportunity to clarify something we
need elected officials held more
accountable than they are held I have no
problem with elected officials current
and former being investigated as part of
a fair judicial process we lack that we
have this de facto immunity that so many
of our elected officials and our elites
have merely because they are in a
position of power but you don't do it by
having the president make a list of
enemies that wants that he wants revenge
on and then forcing the Justice
Department to investigate them this is
exactly why though I'm saying
there have been no consequences for
Donald Trump's actions so why wouldn't
he do this
Russia probe possible cognitive decline
hush money payments campaign finance
violations hiding his taxes emoluments
violations and he's fine
he's continuing to be president he's
making the u.s. a laughingstock why
wouldn't he be emboldened by that and
say hey let me make a list of enemies
and I'll try to get them jailed sometime
soon because he's gotten away with
everything so far and unless we vote him
out on November third he will likely
succeed at triggering at least some
investigation of his political enemies
he will get away with all of it
as far as John Bolton I hope it's clear
to him he has one choice it's not even
really a choice when there's only one he
has to spill the beans period as far as
love Parnas I hope he publishes
everything he has including every video
he has access to but in the meantime
this authoritarian nightmare has to be
stopped one way or the other and there's
really no the other right now the one
way is vote him out overwhelmingly on
November 3rd because nothing else is
having
any effect let me know what you think
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman make sure
you're following me there